in teachers with their
expertise the safer internet centers
should be seen as one stop shops for
child Online safety they are very
valuable asset and we encourage the
member states to promote them as such
this network is helping us gather
evidence on how industry implements you
ask about the industry how industry
implements the digital Service Act
provisions on protection of
miners in 20 22 last year the network of
safer internet centers and the better
internet for kids platform reached more
than 31 million European citizens as
every child matters and no child should
be left behind we are directing these
centers to focus on children with
special needs from disadvantaged and
vulnerable backgrounds and we will
measure this Outreach upcoming features
on the better internet for kids platform
include a parents parent space and and
the teacher Corner this will help us
raise a digitally literate and informed
population but there is more the better
internet for kids strategy goes hand
inand with the digital education action
plan which presents a strategic vision
for an effective and high quality
digital education for All in This vein I
would like to recall the commission's
two proposals for Council
recommendations the first one uh key the
first one on uh
key enablers for Effective digital
Education and Training and second one on
improving the provisions of digital
skills through Education and
Training whatever technology and devices
children use in the coming years the
European Union needs up toate knowledge
on the trends risks but also on
opportunities these present it is key to
continue to invest in European research
as we have done in the past under the
safer internet programs we started EU
kids online which has since become a
global standard for research in the
field we also set up Kore and knowledge
platform which offers Publications and
studies from across Europe on children's
digital lives we are now exploring
funding opportunities to carry out new
research including paneuropean
surveys in addition better internet for
kids plus knowledge Hub and better
internet for kids platform will allow
easy access to evidence and practical
insights on how the digital
transformation is affecting children we
cannot discuss the better internet for
kids without mentioning the role of
young people last year over 470 events
were organized throughout Europe by the
safer internet centers with youth
participation including peer-to-peer
learning and intergenerational learning
young people will also help shape better
intern for kids Plus Code of Conduct and
monitor the implementation of the
strategy as announced in the rights of
of the child strategy the European
children's participation platform is now
up and it is running in partnership with
the European Parliament and child rights
organizations this platform will
systematically involve children and
young people in decision making and
finally if we want children to exercise
their rights they must be able to
understand the language we use the child
friendly version of better internet for
kids plus is available in European
languages and in Ukrainian language and
in a child-friendly explan explanation
of digital Service Act will soon follow
so this is for the beginning I'll listen
to your comments and maybe I have some
more replies thank
you thank you very much Madame
commissioner now on behalf of the
political group the group of the
European People's Party colleague Mr
adamov the floor is
yours colleagues ch children's interest
must be of Paramount importance for All
Digital actions and
decisions affecting their physical and
mental health their safety and their
well-being hence I'm very proud to be a
shadow rapor on two of the most
important files in our institutions to
files that are fighting for a better and
safer internet for our
children in the resolution on a European
strategy for a better internet for
children we emphasize the empowerment of
the young EST because knowledge is the
greatest power we call for development
of specific measures and educational
programs that would enhance their
digital skills and
Literacy for a long time I've been a
teacher and I became convinced of the
key importance of parents in the
educational process parents should be
informed about all available available
digital tools for safe browsing and
surfing as well as online
communication teachers have a key role
here they're partner to the parents and
must be actively working on increasing
their digital competences and media
literacies all should be um working in
that area parents teachers children
family and school must tackle the main
challenges hand in hand because together
we can raise responsible
empowered young
Europeans in the resolution we emphasize
on the need for adapted and specific
punitive measures against the terrible
crimes of child sexual harassment as
well as cyber bullying and its severe
psychological and physical
consequences I believe that with the
current resolution we'll take yet
another step toward creating a safe
inclusive and more accessible digital
environment for every child in the EU
thank you look forward to your support
in the the vote on the resolution later
today thank you very much on behalf of
the group of the progressive Alliance of
socialists and Democrats in the European
Parliament colleague Mr
aru thank you chair one in every three
internet users are
children and every day thousands of
children access the internet for the
very first time children are spending
more and more time on the internet
they're using social media they play
games online and they use smartphone
apps despite all the opportunities which
the internet offers the online world is
not safe for children children may be
easily exposed to inappropriate content
bad behavior sexual abuse pornography or
violence they have psychological
needs their vulnerabilities are easily
exploited
by targeted
advertisements that do not respect
children's safety not to mention of
course the complications brought about
by Chad gbt which is presenting a new
dilemma for policy makers and for for
for parents and I hope that this new
strategy will be able to protect
children from the dangers of the digital
world we should be able to track their
um their internet use and the internet
should be safe for them we
need industry standards for safety we
must Design Services and Digital
Services targeted towards children thank
you very much very much now on behalf of
the renew Europe group colleague Madame
far
Madam president uh 13 years of age is
the minimum to sign up for the main
social media networks young people use
and yet in France for example
63 of under 13s in France are using the
social media and 80% of parents State
they don't know what their children are
doing on those social networks in Europe
23% of European children say they've
already experienced cyber bullying these
children aren't aware of how VIs visible
or vulnerable they are online they use
Snapchat Tik Tok or Instagram in their
bedrooms unsupervised in a world where
they don't know the rules and they have
no handle on what it all
means digital tools are obviously an
opportunity for them but they're also a
major risk factor they may be exposed to
Violent content uh
pornographic content cyber bullying or
face a risk of child pornography and
therefore salute the commission's
willingness to put in place by 2024 a
European Standard on age verification
online this is a complex matter on which
France has already worked in its law
from July on uh the digital age of
majority a European framework will be uh
welcome therefore yes children should
benefit from their digital tools but uh
to deprive them of it would be
counterproductive but it's yes to the
internet but with rules and not without
supervision on behalf of the group of
the greens European free Alliance
colleague
Mame thank you president
commissioner the internet is a key tool
in our daily lives and in the lives of
children and
teenages but can we ensure today that uh
young people have a safe online
environment in my country Catalonia
every day uh one um case of cyber
bullying is reported against minor
and eight and 10 uh young people have
experienced this
the there are a difference between uh
Children and adolescents um they are
responsible for 60% of uh bullying cases
and there is a clear link uh between the
increase in sexual um uh bullying
between minors and the content that they
consume
online uh they receive um reactionary
discourse and are ined by pornography
the European strategy for a better
internet for children is a key step
because the digital world is shaping the
experiences values uh feelings and
perspective of children and
teenagers for us educal uh digital
education is a key pillar for better
internet we need to ensure that children
and IND adolescent particularly the most
vulnerable have the tools and the
information that they need to make
properly informed
decisions so digital education to um
Empower young people and children uh
with uh critical thinking skills so that
they can be key active uh players uh one
that goes beyond uh mere digital uh
skills we also need uh proper uh healthy
sex education the internet should be a
key tool that will help us to lay the
basis for a tolerant diverse and
feminist future Society thank you now on
behalf of the European conservatives and
reformist group
SE dear
colleagues uh we have real risks for are
children on the internet they're looking
at inappropriate contacts for their age
it affects their development their
psychological and emotional
wellbeing so tackling child pornography
and the abuse of mindness online should
be a priority for
everybody and children often start uh
consuming this content around 11 years
old and uh they can experience this
content when they're on online platforms
or playing games
online the consumption of pornography
can be like a drug it creates an
addiction particularly uh when the
children are not yet
mature platforms allow these types of
content these pornographic uh Pages
they're found on the most used social uh
networks uh there's millions of pages of
this type of content but the
requirements uh to control this are not
put in place why are they not on the
list I asked the commission we
need to have effective uh blocking and
checking what's uh crime offline should
also be one online thank you very much
graas now on behalf of the identity and
democracy group
Madame thank you very much Madame
President ladies and gentlemen online
protection of M especially children is
fundamental and of course it's close to
my
heart in the internet age there are many
plus points but uh pornography is just a
click away from children and uh studies
show that there's a massive risk here as
their brains are still developing
children will develop sexual will
confuse sexuality with the pornographic
images they're seeing uh sexual violence
uh symptoms of depression add ition
they're all out there access for the
youngest to pornography can be combed by
a number of solutions already
established in various European
countries warning messages and mandatory
verification of user age uh using the
French model to have National
authorities responsible for protecting
children restrictions on access to
pornographic images for children and uh
parental uh controls
and then uh educational uh act actions a
better internet for children must take
the scourge into account appropriate
measures must be put in place because a
great deal remains to be done thank you
very much meru uh now uh colleague uh
miss Mr Kil Ure I'm sorry I haven't seen
you on behalf of
the thank you Madame President
we are discussing one of the most
important and sensitive issues of
digital era it is our duty to protect
our children and put in place a strong
framework that will provide to
youngsters all the necessary
skills it is of great importance that
digital skills and competences including
media literacy be recognized as
mandatory skills and should be included
in the school curriculum across the
European
Union we must Focus on educating
children parents teachers and with
general public on Online safety and how
to recognize an ort online solicitation
of children the EU and member states
need to invest in supporting victims of
online child abuse or solicitation
including Anonymous public reporting and
in mental health and Psychological
Services for victims and their
families finally I would like to
underline line that children need to be
empowered and public investments in
education are investments to the whole
society thank
you thank you uh next speaker Mr juso
please
colleagues we uh have to uh take the
ball by the horns uh today children uh
from the very youngest age are using
mobile phones devices digital devices
they're online these are these uh
devices are both good and bad uh even
children that don't have them use their
friends the problems are the content
that they see through this technology
and education about how to use this
technology now there's concern of course
about uh young children and minor seeing
pornography but there's also cyber
bullying which is a huge problem that we
should shouldn't forget I think the only
possible solution to avoid uh this type
of damage to raising a whole generation
that's used to online violence and
unchecked violence is education and
that's from the various Earl from the
very earliest ages about how to use this
technology now we have a regulation that
can be used in all member states about
um primary school education use on new
technologies thank you very much next
speaker Mr frankovsky the FL is your
uh president commissioner our children
are our future so it's very important to
give them a safe and secure environment
they are EU citizens they have the same
rights as the rest of us based on the
European Charter of human rights for
instance this includes a digital
rights children are exposed to uh new
technologies on a daily basis therefore
uh the internet should be safe uh uh to
Children what is important as well is
that children should not be mere passive
consumers of Technologies and contents
for this we needs a relevant education
of children but also of parents and
teachers children should be protected
online all children deserve such
protection but bear in mind some of them
require uh better protection for
instance children with disabilities or
children from more susceptible
backgrounds we should all be informed of
and trained on cyber bullying for
instance which is why we put forward
amendments on better
liability for cyber bullying for
instance uh we see good practices for
this in Ireland for example it is good
that the commission has presented good
solutions for the protection of our
children thank you much next speaker
colleag Mr negresco the flooor is
yours commissioner ladies and gentlemen
the internet should be a safe space for
our children there needs to be the right
balance between opportunities and
freedom from the online media and the
challenges posed by by the internet
what's illegal in society should be
illegal online too we can't tolerate uh
victims of online cyber bullying of our
children uh we can't tolerate them being
exposed to inappropriate content U
before the legal age of majority in the
European Parliament we need uh a way of
protecting our children U which is
appropriate for them there need to be
appropriate advice and support there
needs to be
uh a situation where the platforms
shoulder their responsibility so that
they're safe spaces again uh we
shouldn't be left behind by Innovation
and Technology it's our duty to to
explain how to use interet in their own
interests and uh how to use it u
usefully in the European Parliament we
need to come up with the challenges for
the solutions for those challenges thank
you much next speaker colleague Mr B the
floor is yours thank you Madame
chair commissioner ladies and gentlemen
the internet is a technology that our
children have already got used to uh
they uh use it more easily than many
adults uh parents need to be aware of
how they're using it it's absolutely
necessary for schools to include
programs to teach children uh to take a
critical approach to the information
they find on the internet and the way
that the social networks are used and
how to uh protect themselves from online
aggression and digital addiction should
also be dealt with we need to put in
place better protection for children and
we need to teach them how to react we
need to be able to help them and that
needs to be very easily accessible help
the internet can bring many positives
but also very many negatives our
children need to be able to benefit from
the positives and they need to be made
aware of the whole system so that they
can uh protect themselves thank you
thank you very much next speaker
colleague Mr Brier the FL is
yours
pres Madam president colleagues when it
comes to protecting kids and teenagers
on the Internet it's uh important to
listen to them uh we unlike the
commission talked to 8,000 young people
under the 18 age of 18 to see what they
thought young people want to learn how
to protect themselves from these risks
on the internet they don't want to uh be
censored or have their chats and photos
uh monitored as suggested by uh ashla
Vine so we
uh want to have the right uh mechanisms
in uh place but not have bans on
Instagram or Tik Tok just because
they're too uh long young so a kind of
digital house arrest as suggested by
this Parliament young people want to be
able to anonymously use the internet and
to protect themselves perhaps it's uh
political networking um learning about
their
sexuality
and this would be going against our
right to uh anonymity um 85 uh percent
uh could easily uh get an adult open an
account for them so dear
colleagues we need to uh Empower young
people on the internet rather than
taking that power away from them thank
you next speaker colleague Mr ban the
floor is
yours
inter thank you so much president
commissioner internet is everywhere
today uh the majority of young people uh
are using it but also children of an
even younger age this can be very
beneficial educationally speaking but
also as we see in member states it has
also many risks and challenges we are
discussing several days after a huge
Scandal has been revealed in my country
and turned out that that for many many
years a group of internet influencers
was using the internet to grooming and
sexually abusing
miners uh this Scandal uh was kept quiet
uh but it has been revealed a few days
ago uh so it shows that very often the
law does not keep up with the
development of new technologies and also
State institutions EU institutions have
to try to catch up but for this we also
need social changes there can be no
tolerance to such behaviors uh if uh
it's done by people who are known uh or
influential uh and I hope this new EU
strategy that we are discussing will
also see the necessity of changes here
so that the internet is safe and
friendly also for our children thank you
thank you very much next speaker Madame
Beno the floor is
yours
thank you
president uh there's been a 6000%
increase in um online uh child
pornography um most children have seen
uh pornography and uh I'm talking about
children here uh sexual predators use
platforms such as Tik Tok and pretend to
be teenagers they manipulate children
win their trust and then fin encourage
them to share uh intimate
photographs we've seen this Scourge um
insidiously uh take over social
networks we need to see more cooperation
between uh police forces and chanted
Protection
Services uh regulation and um
supervision for the internet needs um
more cooperation with um content
providers who should have a clearly role
a role to play when it comes to flagging
up inappropriate content uh with High
proportion of children now online we
have to act quickly and decisively in
order to protect our children from this
sexual crime thank you mer next speaker
Mr the internet is a wonderful space
where you can be an activist you can
exchange information you can organize
but it's also um be more ambivalent
they're not neutral
areas these online platforms uh you have
a discriminations and biases about one
in three children will face cyber
bullying during their
life there are a lot of young people who
are put in situations of extreme
distress or even end up committing uh
suicide it is it important to give
better tools to schools to manage uh
this type of bullying or harassment to
open up uh challenges to properly listen
to the victim to uh raise awareness uh
and to deal with those responsible for
the bullying as well so we need to have
a more Global strategy that has already
affected too many young people in their
lives thank you next speaker colleague
vice president Madame kopach the floor
is
yours
thank you so much ladies and
gentlemen uh for our youngest generation
the internet is part of reality and
being online is as natural as brushing
your teeth or going to school from the
very earliest age we teach our children
what's good and what's bad we teach them
how to function in society and we should
also teach them how to use the internet
safely the possibilities of the virtual
world safely why so that they that then
they can see the risks that could that
they uh treat other users of Internet
with respect and so that they are not
afraid to ask for our help if there is
something uh worrying them cyber
bullying uh is more and more more
widespread in Poland one in three
children in early school age was
confronted with hate
with cyber
bullying one in five young teenagers was
Cyber Bullied um and 10% of them spread
hateful uh content against their
colleagues and we know that this can
lead to depression low self-confidence
withdrawal social withdrawal even um
suicidal thoughts and actions that's why
we need education and uh effect Ive Pro
prevention programs we also have to have
programs of psychological support for
victims without such activities it will
be more and more difficult for us to
protect our children from harmful uh
content hate and abuse we grown-ups we
should pay attention to the changes in
their behavior we should ask them listen
to them and help them uh thank you
Madame commissioner for this strategy
that has been prepared by the commission
big plus I know uh that you personally
have been very involved thank you so
much thank you very much now let me give
the floor to colleague Mrs
Toya thank you president good morning
commissioner this strategy is certainly
a step forward and we've already done a
great deal uh with the
data protection regulation and the
uh on artificial intelligence impact on
children but I think we have to do a
great deal more it's not just about uh
talking but also putting in place the
elements of this strategy uh technology
has invaded our life permeated through
all fields and it now has power above
all on young people it can be pervasive
and captivating captivating useful but
also potentially dangerous and that
potential danger is where we must take
action and uh we must supervise it and
then uh stop it we must uh do more
especially for young people who often
fall victim as has said uh they're not
just uh participants but victims or
destines of uh things like bullying in
the digital age we need to spend some of
the time and attention on this as we do
on the natural
environment there need to be targets and
limits including uh strict ones that's
what we must to do in this area uh we
mustn't uh worry that this is is too
restrictive because we're talking about
the psychological and mental well-being
of so many young people and lastly we
must do more on education we've got
technical skills here but not much
awareness about all the implications of
the digital sphere so a lot needs to be
done uh on uh education including in
schools thank you thank you very much uh
next
speak thank you president
the technical revolution has left adults
without any kind of instructural manual
and not knowing what to do to protect
children from the risks thank you
commissioner the resolution on the new
European strategy for a better internet
for kids will make us face these
responsibilities we have to act quickly
and we have to get it right just for
example from my country uh awful crimes
uh
using AI generated false images
depicting
miners falsely depicting minals
performing sexually explicit acts uh
perfecting their own uh privacy uh and
then that goes hand inand with
sextortion this is just one tiny example
of the risks that we're
facing big Tech on the other
hand uh the producers they know uh that
technology can be addictive for Miners
and they purposely avoid sharing data uh
we've been asking for a year in this
Parliament for data to be shared and
published because they don't want to
lose a single scend from their business
models and cooperating with legislators
on a topic such as this one so important
can't be voluntary or optional and one
final Point media literacy has
to runs the risk of creating extremist
Fanatics um people can disappear into uh
their own Bubbles and the biases are
forc reinforced by algorithms and so
what's at stake here is democracy I
agree that we have a majority agreement
and thank you commissioner much gracias
now let me give the floor to the next
speaker colle Mrs F sparing
please thank you ask any youngster or
teenager on the street to show you their
screen time and they easily spend seven
hours on their device and while kids are
glued to their devices there's a big
chance they're constantly being shown
more shocking content just to keep them
online and even slowly being dressed
into funnels of extremism hate or
misogyny the super addictive design of
games and online services impacts
children's ability to focus in schools
and problematic use can have serious
mental health effects like risks of
depression anxiety and even effects on
brain
development a better and safer internet
for kids shouldn't only be about
restricting children's with age
restrictions or better
parenting because no one can be the AR
armies of psychologist and strategists
that design manipulative big Tech tricks
to keep us online at all costs we need
to fundamentally tackle the system
behind it because the internet should be
safe for everyone and therefore I call
upon the commission to present rules
against addictive design of online
services and stop dangerous recommender
systems thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much next speaker
Madame Jim the FL is
yours thank you president commissioner
um exposure to inappropriate content
cyber
bullying uh privacy violations
disinformation and
manipulation are just some of uh the
possibilities as we've already
heard there are um concrete risks that
our children are exposed to on a daily
basis the new European strategy for a
better internet with its three um
pillars to ensure uh uh safer digital
experiences uh uh digital empowerment
and active participation of miners in um
monitoring uh and enacting solutions is
something that is going in the correct
direction
however as the strategy says uh we have
to ensure that we are providing support
for schools and parents and children in
uh raising awareness about risks and and
about the tools that they can use to
avoid these risks at the same time we
also have to increase actions aimed
at those who are responsible for
managing content loaded uploaded onto
the
web it's not consistent to hope for a
healthy safe use of Internet by children
with without um ensuring that we adults
are also being the key players uh we
have to set an example thank
you thank you very much next
speaker thank you very much Madame
President ladies and gentlemen
commissioner the internet the social
media uh
Digital Services they're all uh taken as
red for the Young Generation it has
challenges in terms of Education uh
Outreach and uh information but uh as
well as the advantages uh there all also
challenges uh
23% of nine uh to to uh 30 16 year olds
have experienced cyber bullying we must
protect our children this strategy is a
good good one it's a helpful one but
what we're really concerned about is how
it is implemented in
practice a very negative example is
nickl Cox who was Cyber Bullied and uh
took her own life as a result
and only afterwards
uh was a law adopted in Ireland in
2021 um that uh resulted in prosecutions
of uh cyber bullies children shouldn't
just be protected uh that we need to
change legislation at an EU level so we
appeal to the commission that a new
strategy is put in place against cyber
bullying and
U this must be in place in schools a
package must be uh in place with data
collection in cooperation with the
member states and I think we need to do
more to deal with the perpetrators of
cyber
bullying the floor is
yours
graas thank you very much president
commissioner we are seeing our children
use um the internet more intensively at
younger ages we're seeing this more and
more and this leads to problems cyber
bullying sexual abuse online both have
exponentially increased and they affect
the health of uh youngest children what
we need is prevention and education they
are key
tools we need to have better detection
of uh sexual abuse online we need to
ensure that these online platforms are
safer places for all we need to raise
awareness of this silent pandemic of
cyber bullying something that has become
increasingly widespread with mobile
phones and social media platforms now
this is something we've called for on a
number of occasions we need a European
strategy against uh cyber bullying we
need to have the proper package of
measures at a European level and we need
this to be coordinated to create a
better internet for children we have
millions of children who are scared of a
new school year due to bullying and
cyber bullying and we need to act firly
in this area thank you very much much
graas now let me give the floor to the
next speaker colleague Mrs M the floor
is thank Mrs vice president thank you
commissioner the internet can be an
incredible Limitless empowering resource
allowing kids to socialize learn and
play to meet like-minded friends this is
important particularly if their parents
are school friends do not understand or
accept them for the well-being of LGBT
lgbti kids
this is especially crucial we need to
empower our children not put them under
surveillance yes the internet and its
platforms can be dangerous but when
teaching kids to ride a bike we don't
stop access to the bike because they may
fall no we give them stabilizers and a
safe environment to learn we don't stop
kids going to church or sports but we
talk with our kids about their
experiences the same should be true of
the internet we have to ensure a safe
environment and children's privacy and
autonomy recent laws in the US and the
UK enabling parental surveillance are
already harming lgbti plus kids and
putting them at an even higher risk we
must build trust with our children
provide guard rails and Empower them to
seek advice from trusted adults so let's
build an internet where kids can explore
independently in a space that offers
agency privacy and safety thank
you thank you very much next
speaker thank you president
commissioner
uh we have to remember that the internet
entails serious risks for
childrens uh particularly with the
massive use of new AI
tools we have a series of proposals uh
that we have to look at we have to come
up with a real effective uh age
verification mechanism for miners in
order to avoid them having access to
platforms that uh distribute
pornography this uh mechanism can and
must be legal we also at European level
have to to establish a
response to uh a number of uh
phenomena that are experienced uh
regularly
um and experienc on a regular basis
cyber bullying and sexual
bullying that's why we need to have the
right resources for this and we have
to uh act as uh what we have to sound
the alarm in schools and in uh families
uh to avoid this becoming the scourge
that it threatens to be yes now let me
give the floor to the next speaker
colleague Mr tank
please thank you
president which parent would let their
kids walk unsupervised along a busy
highway well in fact we all do we let
our kids walk around the busiest Highway
in the world the internet every day our
kids use use online services that where
Predators often disguise as other kids
Scout for vulnerable potential victims
with numerous example of sex tortion and
SE child sexual abuse it has become very
clear that for our children the internet
is sometimes a dangerous place and this
is why we need online age verification
but to be clear not in any form but
privacy protected and that is certainly
possible zero knowledge proof protocols
allow for Selective disclosure of
attributes it's a simple question are
you older then that's all with a simple
verified answer the highway of the
internet has been built and our children
will use it and we'll have to use it so
let's install the safety bar barriers so
that our kids can enjoy the online world
without getting hit hard thank
you thank you next speaker Mr Kelly the
floor is yours
like with the wide range of it available
to us like the social
media we have opportunities now we've
never seen the likes of before however
with the same
Technologies there is dangerous content
also being distrib ited during the
pandemic we saw a 50% increase in the
time that children spend in front of
screens which means that they are more
vulnerable to cyber bullying and other
forms of abuse in a recently conducted
study UNICEF found
that one out of every three teenagers
had suffered cyber
bullying and 71% of
them said that this danger was more
serious than poverty or violence
therefore we have a huge need for new
law similar to the new law in Ireland to
protect young people children use the
internet and social media more
frequently and from a younger age now
than previously and therefore we need to
act urgently thank you president thank
you very much and now I would like to
give the floor to colleague Mrs hutan
floor is
yours Madame speaker rules that apply
offline must also uh apply online in a
world that feels just as real to many
young people growing up today while most
kids cannot picture life without
internet the bullying and abuse that
take place online can be constant and
literally accompany children into their
homes we must find means to put an end
to this it is also clear that we must
find new tools to stop grooming
violations and the spread of sexual
abuse material online the internet can't
be a safe haven for pred
Predators this is the ambition with a
new regulation laying down rules to
prevent and combat child sexual abuse
commonly called chat
control however rules of privacy clearly
protected in the real world must also
apply in the online world the principle
of secrecy of Correspondence is clearly
jeopardized by the proposed e regulation
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions we must not allow the
well-intentioned ambition to make
internet safe also mean the end of free
communication and the open internet as
we know
it thank you very much next speaker
colle
Mrs kich the floor is
yours thank you president
commissioner uh sexual exploitation
privacy violations uh cyber bullying U
profit making exploitation these are
just a few of the risks for young people
and children in the digital world
internet certainly wasn't uh designed
with children in mind but they are a
third of European users now and they
need specific rules and uh
targeted intervention by legislators and
providers to ensure that the often
dangerous consequences for their psycho
physical health and development uh is
protected and uh bck plus is a good way
of working towards more protective
internet for children and young people
but we need to do more to protect uh
minors
educate them about the risks and involve
uh parents families schools and
Educators to strengthen the protection
of
victims uh commissioner businesses must
in invest in safety by Design measures
to protect children right from the
outset protecting the
smallest uh that's the duty of all of us
and we must work together towards that
objective thank you thank you very much
now let me give the floor to colleague
Mr Duda the floor is
thank you so much for today's debate
which is so fruitful I would like to
strengthen one of the trends here uh the
risks to
psychological uh health for young
children uh young people children
especially um suicides we need
strategies to counter the violence but
also the there is this uh phenomenon of
trying to help with suicide in the
internet we need special um tools for
those children for whom internet is one
of the major communication tools we need
the uh work of street workers therapists
Specialists who know how to reach the
children how to build the contacts and
build relationships with those who are
at risk thank you so much thank you very
much and now I have five speakers ERS on
my kdi list and I will start with Mrs
Novak the floor is
yours thank you very much for giving me
the floor dear commissioner dear
colleagues internet has many benefits it
is attractive but at the same time it is
very dangerous for young people and
children with education awareness
raising needs to be start in the
kindergarten and especially parents need
to to take a key role and they are
already a digital Noma
generation many children also toddlers
are actually deprived of warmth and warm
words from their parents who are
actually focusing on their applications
while they're taking a walk and not
focusing on children also young people
are exposed to dangers because they want
to uh gain more attraction online
I want to point out that also media and
platform providers need to assume
responsibility for that we need to have
appropriate legislation and this is our
role to provide this
legislation thank you very much uh next
speaker thank you uh very much the
average age for consumption of
pornography starts at
11 a lot of parents with children uh of
this age don't believe that their
children are watching pornography they
don't want to believe it but
unfortunately they are this data was um
this data that's been gathered is
extremely
concerning the statistics are clear in
uh Spain we have increase of sexual
assaults by uh minors an increase in the
artificial creation of uh pornography
and it's creating a completely distorted
uh view based on violence these young
people who are consuming this
pornography have aggressive sexual
behaviors so we welcome the commission's
new strategy for a uh better internet
for children that will protect children
when it comes to these new digital
challenges also cyber bullying one in
three children are subjected to this
globally when we look at the Digital
Services act the European education area
uh parents families teachers we need to
use all the resources available to us to
make the internet a safer place for
children thank you very muchas our next
speaker colleague Mrs mazure the floor
is
yours president ladies and
gentlemen making sure that our children
are safe online is a priority for
us we must
Implement educational programs targeted
not only at children but also at their
families and teachers approximately one
in three internet users is a child also
from a very young age and also Al
without any parental supervision which
is why it is so important to create a
trustworthy and safe online environment
for children we must focus on the
creation and implementation of
preventive Technologies and techniques
we must protect our children from uh uh
harmful Contex contents behaviors we
must make sure they are safe therefore
our priority is to raise awareness uh
invest in education so that children
acquire all the relevant knowledge and
expertise in order to be able to take
safe responsible decisions online it is
important to talk about it but it is
even more important to act swiftly now
to make sure our children are safe and
protected thank you much next speaker
colleague Mrs gra
please Madame President commissioner
ladies and gentlemen today is the world
day of education and allow me to pass on
congratulations to all those who are
working for the education of our
children whether it's uh Educators
teachers or parents today on the very
day of Education it's appropriate that
we're talking about something extremely
important namely how to have a strategy
for safe internet for children the
situation in fact shows that violence
has increased in schools cases of su
side uh
uh the cartoons the content and images
in uh
cartoons are a
problem we can't expect teachers and
parents to supervise every minute
obviously the issue here is
content what uh is not allowed offline
should not be allowed to appear online
uh there needs to be protection against
violence uh
uh drug consumption uh is and violence
are on the increase I think we need to
seriously think ladies and gentlemen how
we regulate content thank you very much
very much next speaker colleague
Mrs
thank you
president it's very important for the EU
to implement its um strategy for better
internet for
children um during the pandemic internet
use increased and unfortunately so did
crime it's very important to have
legislative uh projects for example
on um preventing sexual exploitation of
children we also have to look at a
potential age verification
system but what is particularly
important is that all of the
recommendations and um are implemented
and that we cover um models that lead to
Addiction in the legislation all
children need assistance and education
about how to use the internet and that
should take place from the very youngest
age because they start to use the
internet very young at home and also in
schools what's important is that also
every European child should have access
to the internet and uh access to
unlimited information in the world thank
you very much colleagues so this is the
end of our comments and discussion and
now I would like to give the floor again
to Madame commissioner vice president
SCH the floor is
yours
MERS chair we heard a lot I want to
thank you for this uh Rich debate on
this uh let me comment some of you your
comments many of you mentioned the cyber
bullying and um just to clarify with the
entry into the uh with the entry into
application of the digital Service Act
European union now has powerful new
tools to tackle Mental Health risks
online in particular for minors and
young people many of you mentioned the
risk of Psych to psychological Health
the commission will work in close
cooperation with the national digital
service coordinators in the supervisory
framework established by the digital
Service Act some of you mentioned also
effective age verification so we are
working on it just to tell you few on
just to mention few ongoing actions the
commission is is preparing an age
verification uh toolkit on the better
internet for kids platform to raise
awareness of existing eff effective and
privacy preserving methods of age
verification this will include an age
verification self assessment tool for
digital service providers and the child
familyfriendly explanation of relevant
Solutions a first meeting of this age
verification toolkit will take place in
November now around safer internet Forum
uh for this year the commission is also
issuing a standardization request for
European Standard on online age
verification and also the commission is
exploring the development of an European
uh Union wide recognized digital proof
of Age based on the date of birth within
the framework of electronic ID proposal
and building on preliminary work such as
the EU conent pilot projects the the
topic could also be addressed in better
internet for kids Plus Code so there is
um much of ongoing work many of you
mentioned also sexual abuse since sexual
abuse will be uh special uh an extra
legislative uh piece I don't uh I I
don't have enough time to explain this
but as all of you know for us child
sexual abuse is a serious crime with
long lasting actually lifelong
consequences
and it has both offline and online
components as all of you mentioned and
it knows no no no borders so our our
firm position is that children have the
fundamental right to have their best
interest assessed and taken into account
as a primary consideration in all our
actions that affect them but on sexual
abuse we will talk separately regarding
the role of school in education which I
already mentioned in my introductory
remarks for us uh safer internet for
kids centers are the strategies direct
connection and influence with school
with schools across European Union we
are enlarging and strengthening this
network member states have to ensure
that digital education and awareness
Rising become part of the education
curriculum for us schools play a crucial
role in implementation or implementing
the big plus strategy
we are launching large scale media C
literacy campaigns also targeted at
schools and teachers who can act as
multipliers honorable members the
commission seeks to minimize risks and
maximize the opportunities uh the
digital age offers children we will
continue to provide a safer and better
online space for children in line with
the broader legislative framework and
other policy
priorities we will involve children
along the way providing them space to
express their views involving them in
the policymaking and delivering child
friendly
communication as I said the network of
safer internet centers will continue to
be one of the most important
tools of course we aim for all children
including those in vulnerable situations
to benefit from this big
plus I wanted to tell you that we cannot
uh act alone this requires the active
engagement and commitment from Member
States from industry from civil society
and from users themselves and also from
International cooperation so we really
greatly appreciate European parliament's
supports for the new better intern for
kids strategy and for and for this
resolution regarding Empower empowering
children we fully recognize that
importance of empowering children and
giving the them the skills to navigate
the online world conf uh
confidentially themselves this is why
better intern for kids seeks a balance
between empowerment and protection with
children themselves being involved in
all uh Works uh work
streams online protection digital
empowerment and digital inclusion are
European as well as Global challenges
it's not only European so we have to
bear this in Mind by joining forces we
can address these issues more
effectively and more efficiently our
goal must be nothing less than a safe
secure and trusty digital space as a
Cornerstone Stone of our Digital
Society and to to finish for every child
and for for everyone everywhere thank
you thank you very much uh Madame
commissioner Madame vice president so
the debate is closed uh I have received
one motion for resolution to wind up
this debate the vote will be held today
in few minutes uh but the sitting now is
suspended and it will resume at 12:00
with the vote thank you